allora katia questa volta le voglio fare
del colore del mare del posto dove vado
in vacanza ma dove ma devo a riccione
ovviamente marroni bravo hai ragione ma
i reali sono perfetto ma anche da
palamara riesce a fare mura katia sinti
matura 16 agosto c'è il pasto vero ma io
come faccio scusa devo partire 17
proprio giusta che fatti cosi che
chiudete proprio quando la gente era più
bisogno e dai fattelo dire non si fa
senti un po ma se mi si dovesse rompere
proprio l'unghia quando tu sei chiusano
che dobbiamo fare
quindi per te io mi devo tenere le
unghie rovinate proprio quando sono in
vacanza
forse non ci siamo capiti
se mi si rompano le lunghe in vacanza
ovunque tutti i trovi patate inoltre
aerei e ne viene a rifar
primo tema con successo la prende un po
di facebook
[Musica]
senti quanti vivono 65 euro
ma io dovevo nemmeno più da voi ma siete
carissime